in that movie who was the enemy nation  was it uh i mean i think i guess they  were implying it's iran  or or is it russia i didn't think they  were implying any particular nation  state frankly i think they did a  somewhat decent job of having some  ambiguous fifth generation fighters  um  the location and and the stockpile like  i get like how the story kind of  insinuates certain things but they seem  to a good job of not having anything  directly pointing to another nation  which i thought was you know the good  move i i enjoy these type of movies as  an aviator and  you know as an american right because  it's a feel good movie but um you know  we we shouldn't be celebrating going to  war with any particular country you know  china russia whoever may have these  weapons it's it's fun to watch but it  would be an incredibly serious event to  be employing these weapons  you